THYO
HIT IT RELHO  OF NTOODING TCNN.H
IN ILLINOIS,ME JACKPOT O$1.2N.TS
AND RGT LOTTERERE U.S. TICKET
, , 36, 13, AND THGAL OMAR JIMEN
ALL THE
D IVE TICKETS.S ?
FD,E YOSOMUCH, IF WD T BE HERES
THISS CK WITIN
LAST DRAWINGAYANCKEDICD AWAY SIC
NGMOE LIL G
THROUGH E VERIFICATIONCE
FORWARD TO CLAIM THEIRULDN'TBLTH
PR DONE.S LIKEG
SAHET   SO THEY CAN MANI
CKAKERE ISN'SI
GOING ON, BEUS
TE ESPECIALLY  T
IS
>> IPTNFW MEGLLNSHESE
T'LIE ACTUT GREWBIIOLASTASED
LAST-MINUTE
THWINNER ELECTED TCE
RECEIVE $780
GAS STATION IAINES,ETAILELL I
S FOLLE
WE DON'T KNOW WHHEOT THEPRIZE,
ONE  C
UR TICKET.
12 MONTHS FROM
R WEVER  TO R  T.
TH WT T.
AN . RETAILEEC A
LIORSELLINTH ETH YTEAIONVE>> Re
HAT SOE IN ILLS
HAN PRSOMETHING SIHAT
WA HOW TS  LARGEST JACKPOT
EVER WON IIL ER
THE CLD
REMIIOHAAT JACKPOTSTE
.N L S TH FLAT FEE  APEENF ATE N
AMOUN PRIINWHT?SET FEE, IF ,
LET'S SAY, A MILLION DOLRS>>HE,
E MAXIMUM  $ATET
[ INAUBLTI ]CESSING THTHE NEXT
LL RIGHT.DID YOU HEARTHE FOLKS G
MILLIONS, THEY HAVE YER
FROM THENERS OF
TH
N THIS 1.2LL
DOLLARS.
WE KNOW THE BUSINESSS
T'ER JIMENEZ
D E THE BUSINESS OWNN  ARM
AIR?
T GOT
MIDOLLARS, THAT'
.>> I
THEREINAT
THAT, YOU OWN GH THEWO BP AT ST
OR
THATIRS
MPLELYS OF
THECONTIN.
S AN UNBELIEVABLE  I HOPE THIS
I' A
AUSO HAPORSON OR
GR PEOPLWH THAHONE?
THT INOIS AND CO I
ALL RIGHT, WE'LL C